Welcome to Princeton from Sutton, Massachusetts.
Howdy from Phoenix, Arizona.
From GaoShan Taiwan.
From the beautiful city of San Francisco.
Welcoming you from Varansi, India.
This is Christina saying hi from Hong Kong.
Welcome to Princeton from Honolulu Hawaii.
Welcome to Princeton from Seoul, Korea.
Class of 2017, greetings from the great city
of Philadelphia.
Welcome to Princeton from Washington, DC.
My name is Carmina.
I'm currently at the Hagia Sophia in Istanbul,
Turkey.
Welcome Class of 2017 from Phoenix, Arizona.
I'm speaking to you from the second-best place
in the world -- Austin, Texas of course, but
I can't wait to be back at the best -- Princeton
University.
Welcome to Princeton from San Francisco.
Welcome to Princeton from Venice, California.
Welcome to Princeton form Florida.
I'm currently back home in Las Vegas, Nevada
this summer.
Welcome to Princeton from the Jersey Shore.
From my home town of Chicago.
Welcome to Princeton from St. Louis, Missouri.
Now before you all arrive on campus in just
a few weeks, your USG wanted to give you a
warm welcome, and some words of advice to
get you jumpstarted into an exciting Princeton
career.
One piece of advice that I would give you
is to write yourself a letter at the beginning
of the school year, and then read it after
you graduate.
It'll be really cool to see how much you've
grown over these four years.
Good luck!
I think the best experiences are had with
an open mind so just come to campus being
very, very excited, because everyone is excited
to have you here, and Princeton took you on
campus for a reason so just be yourself.
This was my home for nine months during my
Bridge Year experience, and I want to tell
you that Princeton can send you around the
world, but also you can find the whole world
right at Princeton.
We're really excited to have you and I can't
wait to meet you.
Namaste!
Don't be afraid to try new things keep an
open mind because you'll never know what you'll
love, and enjoy the summer but know it gets
way better in the fall.
Try to things, meet new people and remember
to take time to enjoy your surroundings.
You never know who you'll meet or what you'll
find out about yourself along the way.
Talk to other students and upperclassman about
what their favorite courses and professors
were.
Freshman year is a great time to explore.
There are so many people to meet and there
are so many things to do, and I encourage
all of you to take advantage of the many opportunities
you will have to get out there and meet your
peers, your professors, and meet the amazing
people in the Princeton University community.
Know when you arrive on campus don't feel
confined your high school self you're going
to be a new face here and use this chance
to explore new interests, become friends with
everyone that you meet, and who knows what
incredible things will find in your new home
at Princeton University.
My favorite thing about Princeton by far as
the people, so get pumped to be around some
to be around amazing, inspiring, and people
you can just learn from.
They're going to become your best friends
over the next four years.
Don't jump in it too many hard classes to
quickly.
Don't overload yourself your freshman year
you'll be exploring the different groups,
the heart scene, your social life, and making
a lot of friends.
So trust me, you don't want to spend your
whole time in the library.
Don't ever feel intimidated.
So when you step foot on campus, know that
you do belong here, know that these next four
years will be challenging but rewarding, but
also know that in the end, only you can determine
your success.
Remember that even though you're about to
get a ton of independence and freedom, it's
your family that's there to support and encourage
you.
So don't forget to call your parents every
once in a while.
Make sure you follow your passions.
Study what you want and what interests you,
and not what you think will make a lot of
money or make your parents happy, because
in the end, you only have four years at Princeton,
and you want to be able to look back on them
and know that you make the most of them by
doing what you love.
I have four primary pieces of advice.
One.
Organize the files on your computer starting
freshman year, so that when you're a senior
you can find stuff again.
It's terrible.
Two.
Go to office hours.
Professors and TAs love talking to students,
and you'll learn as much from them just kicking
it in their office as you would in class.
Three.
Email professors that you haven't even taken
class with.
For the most part, they love talking to students,
and you can learn a lot from them just hanging
around.
And four.
Spend more time in the town.
It's beautiful, and nothing treats you quite
as nice after a long day in Firestone or Frist
as a nice stay-cation in Palmer Square.
Just bring a book, grab some iced tea, it's
beautiful.
Again, we're stoked to have you join the Princeton
fam - see you in a few weeks.